you've recently talked about effective
altruism on your podcast I think you
mentioned some interesting statement I'm
going to horribly misquote you but that
you'd rather live in a world like it
doesn't really make sense but you'd
rather live in a world where you care
about maybe your daughter and son more
than 100 people that live across the
world something like this like where the
calculus is not always perfect but
somehow it makes sense to live in a
world where it's irrational in this way
and yet empathetic in the way you've
been discussing right I'm not sure what
the right answer is there or even
whether there is one right answer there
could be multiple you know Peaks on on
this part of the moral landscape but so
the the opposition is between an ethic
that's articulated by someone like the
Dalai Lama right or really any exponent
of of
um you know classic Buddhism would say
that is the ultimate enlightened ethic
is true dispassion with respect to
friends and strangers right so that you
would the you know the mind of the
Buddha would be
truly dispassionate you would love and
care about all people equally
and by that light it seems some kind of
ethical failing or at least you know
failure of of to really fully actualize
compassion in the limit or you know
enlightened wisdom in the limit
um to care more or even and much more
about your kids than the kids of other
people or and to prioritize your your
energy in that way right so you spend
all this time trying to figure out how
to keep your kids healthy and happy and
you'll attend to their my nudist
concerns and however superficial and and
again there's a genocide raging in Sudan
or wherever and it takes up less than
one percent of your bandwidth I'm not
sure it would be a better world if
everyone was running the Dalai Lama
program there I think some
prioritization of
one's nearest and dearest ethically
might be optimal because we will all be
doing that and we'll all be doing that
in
a circumstance where we have certain
norms and and laws and and other
structures that Force us to be
dispassionate where that matters right
so like when I go to
when my daughter gets sick and I have to
take her to to a hospital
you know I really want her to get
attention right and I'm worried about
her more than I'm worried about everyone
else in the lobby but the truth is I
actually don't want a totally corrupt
hospital I don't want a hospital that
treats my daughter better than anyone
else in the lobby because she's my
daughter and I've you know bribed the
guy at the door or whatever you know or
the guy's a fan of my podcast or
whatever the thing is you don't want
starkly corrupt unfair situations
and when you're when you sort of get
pressed down the hierarchy of Maslow's
needs you know individually and and
societally
a bunch of the bunch of those variables
change and they change for the worse
understandably but yeah when things are
when everyone's corrupt and it's you're
you're in a state of of uh Collective
emergency you know you've got a Lifeboat
problem you're scrambling to get into
the Lifeboat yeah then then fairness and
norms and and
um the you know the the other vestiges
of civilization
begin to get stripped off we can't
reason from those emergencies to normal
life I mean in normal life we want
Justice we want fairness we want we're
all better off for it even when the
spotlight of our concern is focused on
the people we know the people who are
friends the people who are family people
we we have good reason to care about
we still by default want a system that
protects the the interests of strangers
too and and we know that generally
speaking interesting in game theoretic
terms we're all going to tend to be
better off in a fair system than a
corrupt one